out there we're we're trying to steer
clear of any commentary about the major
topic of the day which has a lot of
people upset and depressed and angry and
the country frankly feeling even more
divided than it was 24 hours ago so one
thing that brings us all together as the
ratings continue to prove day after day
week after week month after month year
after year it's football specifically
professional football specifically the
national football league so
football only segment we talked about
the issues with the potential outbreak
with the titans and the idiocy from guys
like derek carve the raiders last hour
this is back to football based on three
weeks in the can 48 games of the regular
season headline versus story perception
versus reality we've got several
different topics to get to and let's
begin with the three-and-oh seattle
seahawks yeah russ is cooking let russ
cook and russ is cooked like no one has
ever cooked before 14 touchdown passes
in three weeks a record four more
touchdown passes in each of his first
three games this year a record but it's
the story
that the team's defense the legion of
boom
has become the legion of
a four-letter word that doesn't begin
with b or end with m but i guess the
letters b and m would be relevant to the
word i'm thinking of chris
please go before i make it anymore it's
very interesting here i think i should
let you go more actually no no i'm
i will stop so i will i will pick one
like am i supposed to go one or the
other like headline verse story and like
that's i'm okay good well either way all
right we know russ is cooking all right
that that's the real deal all right but
yeah the story the seahawks the stehok's
defense is bad but i don't think that's
the story i still think it's russell
wilson i mean yeah yeah we know the
seahawks bad i mean look at these
numbers i've never seen numbers like
this next to any team
almost 500 yards a total offense in each
game right now four i know but for the
other team pete you know they're letting
up 497 yards of offense for the other
team be quiet you then all right passing
yards aloud 430 that's insanity that's
insanity yes the seahawks d is it's bad
they can't rush the passer and they
don't have good cover corners so that's
not a good combo
but i don't know if they care
i mean
that the bad seahawks d can't be the
story when you're 3-0 and winning
football games still and
it's working out in their favor and the
big thing is this even though they let
up all those yards right last week
their defense is the one that made the
game-changing plays still whether it's
the interception at the end of the game
the strip sack fumble that set up a
short field for the seahawks to start
the second half or the interception at
the end of the first half that gave them
points too so you know maybe you can
live with yards when you're making a few
plays that kind of dictate the game as
well
but here's the thing yeah
when you are
in possession of a quarterback right who
is having a historic run now look 13
games left there's no reason to assume
it's going to continue all year but
based on what we've seen so far there's
no reason to think it can't russell
wilson is running rings around the
defenses they're letting him throw the
ball down the field it isn't wait until
the fourth quarter and rusko please save
him no
when you have that kind of performance
and i think back to
week one of the 2013 season this was
before you were part of the nbc family
we were out in denver for the game it
was when the ravens had to go on the
road for the first game of the year
because they couldn't play their season
opening game right
because the orioles had a game and they
refused to step aside like the the
mighty orioles i don't know much about
baseball but i know the orioles stink
and they've stunk for decades yeah they
have but but uh
peyton manning began a historic run that
night that would lead to 55 touchdown
passes and set a record and they beat
the crap out of the ravens it wasn't
even close
the seahawks
are barely winning right the last two
weeks and the game against the falcons
could have gone either way it was that
fourth down throw to dk metcalf that was
the turning point so what when you i
mean this is the first time that i can
remember that we've seen this kind of
performance by a quarterback that is
tearing up the league but his team is
still barely winning the games they have
to have a stop of cam newton at the goal
line they have to have the interception
in the end zone and that tells me this
may not be sustainable and the only way
to have a chance of sustaining it is if
russell wilson
continues to throw four or five
touchdown passes a week chris yeah i
mean no i mean you're right now i
like i think he can do that and they can
still do that with the weapons they have
they're protecting pretty good and
really
one of the mvps of football for me and
just like a little chris sims world is
the offensive coordinator brian brian
schottenheimer i mean to me it's been
the most impressive
coaching transformation i've seen in a
while i mean seattle
he's reinvented their offense i mean
they were used to be so stagnant and i'd
sit there and watch plays and just go i
mean i've already seen this is the
second quarter i've seen that play three
times already like that's really what we
did i mean schottenheimer's doing it all
motions shifts different formations
different pass patterns down the field
so i give them a lot of crap i don't
know if it's sustainable i think it is
sustainable just because it is russell
wilson it's the seahawks they're
comfortable playing in these type of
football games it does scare me that
jamal adams isn't out there but like
we've said through the first three weeks
the defense has made the big play when
they need to and i feel like that's the
way they're comfortable playing that
style this year they feel like that's
the best way to to field their team
their defense ain't going to stop crap
so it's not going to change i don't
think it's gonna change very much here
anytime soon
yeah i agree with you and if they want
to continue to win football games
they're gonna need russell wilson to
keep doing what he's done because the
defense is going to continue
to let them down and to see those
numbers to see
that
ranking attached to the seahawks that's
what's got to be driving pete carroll
crazy i think it's one of the reasons
why he resisted letting russ cook as
long as no doubt
is
contrary to everything he's ever learned
like i said last week his mentor wasn't
don coryell it was bud grant right this
is contrary to pete carroll's view of
football this isn't how you win because
that's a thing one bad day for russell
wilson your defense can't overcome it
your defense isn't going to step up on
that day that russell wilson throws a
few interceptions and is off a little
bit and for whatever reason they have a
plan that confuses confounds and
contains him your defense can't save the
day and i think that's the ultimate
irony here and i think it would be irony
if this effort to let russ cook
ultimately results in a playoff game
playoffs where russ can't cook and the
defense can't do jack squat well that
that'll be we'll see up to this point
we're not seeing it you know into what
you're saying too we got to give pete
carroll credit there we do i mean the
fact that he finally
went all in defensive head coaches they
always want to just go let's just get a
lead and i'll protect it and they're
completely fine usually with winning a
game 16 to 10 or 13 to 10 and whatever
that may be let's not be aggressive or
increase the chances of us making a
mistake and doing any of that but you're
you know he's changed and i give him a
lot of credit you don't see defensive
coaches do that much
you know you don't you don't see it it's
like bill belichick he's one of the
first guys ever to do it and that's why
they've stayed on top of the mountain
for 20 years because he went waiting
with defense and run the ball and saw
how the league turned out and then he
had this quarterback and he found a
viewer he said wait this is the strength
of my team let's spread the field out
let brady throw it 45 50 times i know i
like defense and like to manage a game
like bill parcells back in 1987 but this
is the strength of my team and i think
that's where i get pete carroll credit
just at least see that and we'll see
they're a work in progress on defense
maybe they can get that straight but i'm
not looking another 3-0 team that will
at some point play the seahawks this
year is the buffalo bills headline josh
allen playing like an mvp
story
could the bill's defense be slipping
this year in comparison to the
performances we've seen in recent years
chris yeah i'm a little like i mean josh
it's a lot this is a lot like you know
the seattle story first off i mean
yeah the the headline is still the story
to me because they're winning the games
and they're winning the games because of
that headline the guy that josh allen is
playing like an mvp just like seattle
you know it's the same type of thing but
like i understand the story the bills d
is slipping i mean that's concerning to
me it is i mean it's not the same d as
last year they're not as dominant up
front
mcdermott got a little exposed in the
run game last week by mcveigh and i
think the other thing is this mic too
that i think i take into account
when you start to have an offense like
the bills do
teams start to go
whoa it's a little like the kansas city
thing sometimes where teams just go wait
we gotta push the envelope here or we're
gonna have to move the ball
because they're gonna move the ball josh
allen and those receivers they're gonna
score points and do those things so
we're gonna have to be more aggressive
going after this bill's defense and i i
think that's probably part of the reason
too to where teams have had to do that
but uh certainly not the same good
defense we've seen at a buffalo the last
few years they're struggling right now
and here's the thing and we've talked
about this as it relates to other great
quarterbacks the best way to slow them
down is to keep them on the sidelines
sipping gatorade if you can run the ball
the way the rams ran the ball against
the bills on sunday even when down late
now you know maybe one of the reasons
the run was there is because the bills
were expecting the past but even before
the game was yeah it was running on it
the rams were running it well right uh
that may be your key run the ball take
the full 40 seconds this part isn't
complicated when you believe there's a
talent gap when you believe they've got
a superstar offense you keep them off
the field because then you frustrate
them when they're on the field they feel
like they have to do too much when they
get their opportunity because they've
had to stand there for 10 minutes while
you have methodically driven the ball
down the field and chewed the clock yeah
and it makes people upset and it does
frustrated they feel like you're
cheating in some way come on call the
next play let's go let's keep the game
moving yeah those are all ingredients to
getting a guy
and a team an offense a coach a
quarterback whoever off of their family
preferred mindset they get upset they
get frustrated that's what you want no
you're you're right you're right about
that and you know i think that plays a
little bit into hey it's you know
mcdermott being in the afc east now for
what this is his fourth season people
getting a feel for what he does that way
you know team's just figuring out some
of the nuances of how he calls a game on
the defensive side of the ball
and you're right i think teams are a
little bit wary of hey let's let's go on
a long drive here let's give our defense
you know some some a breather on the
sideline but we saw the dolphins in week
two and of course last week the rams
teams go on sustained drives and being
able to kind of pick them apart run for
a few plays here and there and one issue
i have with the buffalo that does scare
me
you know they don't they don't have a
great cover corner group there they
don't they play zone defense a lot and
as good as treydavious as white is as a
good cover corner really great zone
cover corner he's not a lockdown island
type guy and that's their other issue
too at times where i feel like they give
up
you know some easy completions here and
there just because they're not playing
man and if mcdermott doesn't orchestrate
the zone the exact right way there's
going to be holes in it that way and uh
i think that's the leads to some of
their issues as well
next topic the texans 0-3
but are they the victims of a
ridiculously brutal schedule and a team
that can turn it around now that the
schedule begins to soften chris well it
is a brutal schedule there's no question
but they are still 0-3 and it hasn't
been like
pretty
you know the first two games they really
like never had a chance right i mean
they really didn't it was over pretty
like early in the football game where
you felt like hey the chiefs got this
one in hand the ravens got this one in
hand last week they hung around
but there's still issues with this
football team that are really concerning
i mean
pass protecting not getting all the not
getting the ball to all the weapons they
have the offense hasn't been able to
really you know conform to the wide
receiver by committee they can't run the
football
their defense stinks
people running wide open so i mean
yes it's a brutal schedule but they're
still 0-3 and to me they've looked like
an 0-3 football team i do believe that
you know billy o'brien's a hell of a
coach and we'll see if they can bounce
back but you know yeah the schedule's
tough but they've looked open three to
me too
yeah we won't know until it shakes out
yeah and until they start playing teams
in their division that's going to be the
key they've got those six games against
the colts the titans the jaguars we'll
see what they do there but you don't
want to lose so many games out of your
division that you don't have a chance to
be competitive in your division and this
is one of the prices you pay for winning
the division that's why they're playing
the champions of the other divisions
that's right in their conference and
that's just the way it works and now
they've kind of gotten that out of their
system we'll see what they can do moving
forward but uh you know they've known
since the schedule came out this is how
it was going to go and i'm sure that
that bill o'brien would have said before
this season boy if we could just win one
of these three yeah and whether that
storm that's good and they lost all of
them and now they get a chance to take
on a winless vikings team but if they
lose this weekend
then i think it's time to become very
concerned about whether or not the
houston texans can be competitive let's
flip it around though the bears right
undefeated at 3-0
nick foles now starting moving forward
mitchell trubisky's reward for going 2-0
was getting benched uh during a game
that he probably would have lost if he
hadn't been benched but nick foles won
the game
how much of it do we attribute to the
bears being back like they were two
years ago the headline they're three and
oh is the story that they've just
feasted on a trio of weak opponents well
yes they're not back so like i i look at
it really this one a little bit and go
like
okay yeah the story to me is still the
story it's been an easy schedule yes
it's awesome the headline that they're
3-0 definitely but i don't know if i can
sit here and tell you like how good i
think this bears football team can be
quite yet i'm seeing some
resemblance
of
the team we saw two years ago i mean the
way the defense played in the second
half against the falcons and going i
don't know four or five series in a row
but just steamrolling them and
dominating them and really got screwed
over with a few other calls in the game
where like i know i think we talked
about this on monday i mean the bears
got called for penalties where it was
like they steamrolled the falcons so bad
the referee i think was concerned for
the safety of the falcons and he threw
us through a flag he was like whoa
illegal killing the other team i mean
that's really what it was it kind of
pissed me off actually but um
the their
naggy
is trying to run the ball they're trying
to play a tougher brand of football and
the defense is pretty healthy and i
think it is one of the better defenses
in football and now can foals just give
them enough i don't you know i don't
know if they're ever going to be a
superstar offense but it sure looked a
lot better with him on the in the game
the other day than mitchell trubisky i
can't deny that i've defended trubisky
and all that but it looks way better i
watched that game film yesterday so um
it is an easy schedule i think that's
why they're 3-0 but i think they're a
team we should circle and jenna just say
watch out for them because they could
become something
and here's the thing these wins in
september really are money in the bank
you get to 4-0 right
if you're a 500 team the rest of the way
you're still ten and six
that that that's how amazing it is to
get off to that good start right you you
can regress when you rack up wins early
you still are in great position to make
it to the playoffs and ten and six most
likely is going to get you in in a seven
team field in the nfc so uh they're
they're one win away from being in that
position where yeah they could become
mediocre and still make it to the
playoffs big test this week with the
call we'll see yeah and then short week
with tom brady in the buccaneers on
thursday night these next two games are
going to tell us a lot about where
you're right exactly similarly a team
that was better a team that made the
playoffs in advance to the final four
last year titans are 3-0
now we know they've got other issues to
deal with now with the outbreak but
they're 3-0 but again you look at the
teams they've beaten
how much of it is the titans are good
how much of it is the titans are and i
can't say feasting they're barely
beating they've won by a combined total
of six points three games against teams
that are winless chris uh titans are one
of the like uh enigmas not winless the
jaguar the jaguars are one and two one
and two right yeah but i mean they're
one of the enigmas of football right now
though the tennessee titans i mean good
for them they're one of those teams
where you look at you go they're three
and oh like you always say vrable will
be able to go but we haven't even played
good football yet you know it's that
perfect type of scenario where he goes
we played like crap and we're 3-0 guys
come on um
you know i i i guess one of my biggest
issue of course with the tennessee
titans and everything like that is yeah
great you're 3-0 but i worry about that
damn defense i just can't believe that
that's i'm shocked by that
by the amount of guys in the secondary
and some of the names we got and the
defense the front seven i mean the way
teams have run the ball on them the last
two weeks robinson with jacksonville was
gashing them everywhere dalvin cook got
to you know ignite all three
afterburners the that are up his butt
there in that game to take off for big
touchdowns so i'm not sure what they are
yet either and you know the defen the
offense has looked
like had moments of looking real good
but again i guess what worries me there
is they haven't played a great defense
really not even a good defense to this
point other than that broncos
so so defense right now in the nfl so uh
uh they're to me one of the biggest
question marks in the in the game right
now i'm very interested to see where
they go at this point their schedule
starts to get tougher here and we're
going to find some questions about them
too or answers but these close games
these close games beyond the fact that
the wins are money in the bank learning
how to win these close games battle
testing will bode well for the titans
when they get deeper into the season and
when they get to the playoffs if they
get to the playoffs right now it looks
like they they probably will be back
again in the postseason
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports